So, I'm starting with a look at the new animation features in Unreal Engine 5.0.
We've got coverage on some of the animation node functions that are new to the editor
and also we'll look at the folder structure being slightly different than how you may
have seen it before.
So animations are now stored in the sequences folder.
So if you go to content, Manikin for example, if you are looking at the Manikin, the animations
folder there, you've got the sequences inside of that folder.
You can also edit in Sequencer with or without Control Rig and we'll talk about that later
in the presentation.
Some other new features mentionable.
With 5.0 there have been many added improvements regarding animation.
So some of these improvements include an IK retaggator and IK rig.
So essentially what we're saying here is that retaggating animations from one skill
set to another no longer uses the retaggating manager.
So using these two new tools, a new workflow has been created there.